c'est comme ça aujourd'hui parce que
c'est la journée sans pantalon êtes au
courant c'est devant des parents
sandrine comment ça va alors guillaume
genton qui est un petit nouveau
c'est un spécialiste médias dits doux
tout doux tu viens guillaume je viens
d'ici sur les i tous les jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
elle dit
mais ce film qui traite d'un sujet
important
les clichés et les femmes dans le sport
c'est dérange fait du sport un oui mais
on ignorait minton va pas en faire
maintenant
[Rires]
enfin battu par messieurs c'est la tombe
et minton permet c'est madame vous êtes
en tournée
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis bientôt bah je sais pas
l'internet a vu la voie même si vases
issus tant une souris verte
c'est la version algérienne
emmenez moi au bout de la terre emmenez
moi au pays des merveilles alors ce mot
car phénomène loin
combien il boit beaucoup dans le film
contrairement à la réalité
j'ai pas composé beaucoup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
géraldine a raison c'est que c'est très
difficile de jouer un abruti bah oui je
voulais pas te déranger
thibault comme ça on a une émission
après je sais c'est moche et donc
takenne pas te crève pas trop où
ouattara est très beau ça ça ne va très
bien laurent baffie merci
il est beau parce que les beaux gosses
le droit il est beau gosse de riche et
riddim amour des relou qui viennent une
fois qu'ils repassent après je sais
c'est passé samedi face à castres et ses
pattes et si tu t'appelles tu n'as pas
une petite blague avant pour le non
[Musique]
merci
des tracts ont en effet dû revoir est à
l'essai pousse à paul huchon ou toi avec
les stars faire tout petit peu on est
sûr et là on est sur un carré plongeant
ça y est on y est moche et je suis très
content de moi c'est vraiment mes potes
je voulais dire encore une fois et on va
le dire igor et grichka on est comme ça
46 pts 2 les cas c'est moins d'un
français sur le voile a fait l'amour
trois fois par semaine et vous igor et
grichka sans indiscrétion
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc on peut dire non non non non
non soit ici encore une question de la
crise' d'accord nous ici d'un design
d'accord très bien ça fait combien
d'années gnépa donc écoute sur comment
c'est un jeu non sans rigoler vous
dormez pas du tout non d'or un peuple
entre une heure et deux heures par nuit
sans rigoler ça soit tu te monde le sait
gilles verdez qui est de retour dans
l'émission gilles verdez abu gilles
verdez les chéris c'était ça s'était
s'agi berra et hier dans l'émission je
lui ai promis de le relooker sur la tête
de ma mère qui les frais de la vie
depuis
margot robbie s'avance puisque
apparemment c'est moi qui vais aller la
voir à londres attendra je vole dit oui
je suis en train d'organiser et
peut-être qu'on entrevoit organisé entre
nos deux attachées de presse
une rencontre à londres où london to be
et nan gang starr et bien sûr c'est vrai
que secret d'histoire on en a besoin
bien sûr oui c'est nécessaire mais c'est
nécessaire et stéphane merde c'est là où
les meilleurs je suis désolé il se boit
ses paroles à l'époque le roi copuler
devant un public parce que vous allez
savoir si la reine ep en scène d'avatar
ou ans n'dour ou bien sûr c'est ce que
je vais faire bientôt
après le panneau des délits sexuels
c'est pour ça que c'est trop douloureux
chaque rapport avec aziz deux minutes on
entend pas il a dit qu'il avait trois
coups y aurait volé 300 malheureusement
qui dénonce à l'abattée ton milieu qui
leur histoire récente et 31e y
le roi alors moi il arrivait en face du
siège qui nappe et tout le monde je vais
bien je suis rennais des gens c'est un
honneur que d'assister aux vrais
contrôles y avait des maquis le matin
c'est les gars y avait des gars qui
devait distribuer des flyers
aujourd'hui notre invité c'est mon
avenir vos frères bouder comme pour
spectacle s'appelle goudé riespach ce
matin sa belle idée on s'est dit on va
jouer avec des bacs ou celui qui gagnent
on verra un mac do à la gueule non
c'est le gars
ça va
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour lui demander un
animateur de prendre votre fils dans
quelques années sur l'émission de télé
un chroniqueur bien ce que je pourrais à
oui oui bon une deux tonnes de boue très
bien et je réponds grave je serai très
bien c'est d'être chroniqueur de votre
fils ah oui là ça commence à faire mal
pour le fils d'ailleurs qu'à croiser
benjamin castaldi n'ont hélas year we
really comme vous une mamie il m'a dit
m'a frappé non mais c'est vrai si c'est
vrai bien sûr l'innovation pas charrier
quand même je n'ai pas répondu il a 8
ans celui de patron d'avoir un enfant
donc les gens passaient sur twitter oui
il vous dit bonjour il est mais on peut
s'il vise le genou comme vous qu'il est
un peu il un peu chaud jusqu'à une fois
j'avais croisé j'avais crié ça vanne sur
quoi il faisait ses vannes j'étais
désolé et du coup je crois je vis je
suis désolé d'avoir grillé tavannes il
me dit ça m'étonne pas tu es une banane
au balajo il fallait il a planqué mener
mes baskets quand on était en train de
changer
je n'ai jamais pris 45 minutes pour la
retrouver au barça c'est très amusant
[Rires]
des questions rapidement jean-michel eux
et ils aussi branleur que vous le dites
ou bien vous en rajoutez un peu pour le
show jean-michel à c'est à moi qui avais
réussi l'a gagné et je le prouve son jeu
gagne souvent les jeux et cetera je
bosse énormément alors peut-être
différemment parce que je suis plus
rapide que les autres mais regardez si
je regarde les rippeurs sûr j'ai ma
fibre optique qui marche pas ne pas
gagner tous les programmes mais je
travaille énormément rageuse à mon ami
en tout cas je me suis là 15h15
aujourd'hui on tombe que vous êtes
connerie est prêt je fais pas trop rêver
à 10h du mat leber mais jamais le
deuxième à 10h30
je regarde quand je regarde mon
téléphone je vois que j'ai des textos tp
travaux et je mens pas je m'en charge
mois
[Applaudissements]
parmi les caméras dans les loges